So I'm still collecting invoices from my October
2nd appendectomy.
So far they total about 6,500 under
dollars, but I'm still waiting for what's
called the facility fee, which includes the
operating room, the anesthesia, the volume,
the staples that they use.
You know all of that stuff.
So when I have it all, I'm going to come to
you with a full detailed accounting for my
appendectomy.
But I do now have the proposed changes to
my health insurance plan if I keep the same
plan going into 2020 and I think this will
be really informative because it's going to
actually expose the disgustingly broken nature
of how our healthcare system and health insurance
system is fundamentally organized at a base
level and should really sound the alarm as
it's obviously, it's not just me who sounding
the alarm, but this will once again sound
the alarm is another data point for why the
system needs to change.
So I live in Massachusetts, Massachusetts
considered to be one of the better places
to be thanks to Romney care, sort of precursor
to Obamacare when it comes to health insurance.
A very close to total health coverage here
in Massachusetts.
Mass health is a program that is very popular
for people who have it on the basis of their
income.
Since I have my own business, um, and I exceed
the income limits for a subsidized plan or
a mass health plan, I just buy my plan through
something called the Massachusetts health
connector.
I, it's unsubsidized, it's just, it's a market
for people who are self employed or whose
job does not offer health insurance.
So I just pay for the plan.
Now I chose what's called a silver plan.
They go bronze, silver, gold.
I think there were still platinum plans, although
I'm not sure.
Of course the higher you go, the more you
pay monthly, but the less you pay when you
need things done.
Silver for me seemed sort of like the right
balance between the monthly premium and how
much I have to spend when I actually get care
of different kind.
So in 2019 my plan costs $421 per month.
That's what I pay out of pocket.
So let's dig into how my plan will change
between 2019 and 2020 I was just notified
of this if I stick with the same plan.
So for starters, my premium goes from four
21 to four 58 okay.
An extra $37 a month.
That's about a 9% increase in what I pay for
the premium.
But the plan also gets worse in terms of what
will be covered.
So my annual deductible stays the same.
It's $2,000 for my appendectomy, for example.
It like I'm going to owe my full $2,000 deductible.
Of course, in addition to the $421 monthly
payments that I'm making, my plans out of
pocket maximum is going up from $6,500 this
year to $8,150 in 2020 so the out of pocket
maximum is the most you would have to pay
for all covered services in a plan year.
So my deductible's 2000 imagine that I have
three or four instances, uh, medical events
where I pay the $2,000 deductible this year.
Once I've paid 6,500 total, my insurance would
cover everything next year.
That limit is being raised to 81 50 okay.
My primary care poke copay is going from $30
to $50.
Remember my premiums going up as well, and
in addition it will cover less.
My primary care copay going from 30 to $50.
My specialist copay going from 50 to $70.
If I go to a dermatologist, for example, or
a podiatrist, as many of you know, I went
to back in June, that's still not resolved
by the way, my urgent care copay, you might
remember earlier in the day of my appendicitis,
I went to urgent care.
I had a $55 copay.
That copay goes up to 70 next year for blood
work and imaging like x-rays.
This year I had a $50 copay after my $2,000
deductible was met.
Next year it's going up to $75 per instance.
After my deductible is met, emergency room,
uh, this year my deductible is 350 my copays,
$300.
Next year it goes up to three 50 of course
after the deductible is met.
So I am going to be paying, if I want to keep
this plan an extra $37 a month, that will
make my yearly premium $5,500 and then I still
have to hit a $2,000 deductible for lots of
things and to have even higher copays in other
areas like primary care specialists, urgent
care and in the emergency room.
I want to go back, I think I might have misstated,
uh, the 81 50 annual limit is the deductible
of 2000 plus additional copays and everything
else.
It is not multiple deductibles.
I, I may have been unclear about that and
I apologize.
So this is considered good insurance in the
individual market and Massachusetts is considered
a good place to be.
This is insane.
The system has to change and we're going to
go into this in more detail when I spell out
the appendectomy costs that I incurred last
month.
But part of what makes this not work, part
of what makes this system the wrong one is
that there is completely inelastic demand
for a great portion of healthcare services
using appendectomy.
As an example, if I don't have appendicitis,
my demand for appendectomies is zero.
It's not like with many other consumer products.
If appendectomies are 10,000 thousand dollars
I don't want one.
If the appendectomy is $5,000 I sort of want
one at $1,000 I really want one and at a dollar
I would want multiple appendectomies.
I might as well take advantage because that's
such a good deal.
No, that's not how it works, but then once
you have appendicitis, your demand is also
not affected by the price.
If you have appendicitis, I can testify to
this.
If the appendectomy costs a dollar or $1,000
or $100,000 you need it and you need it right
away and your demand for it is not impacted
by the price.
Compare this to, for example, a Tesla.
If a Tesla costs $100,000 it might be totally
out of your price range.
Your demand is effectively zero at $50,000
it's a big stretch, but you're certainly more
interested in it than at $100,000 if the Tesla
is $15,000 now you're very interested.
If the Tesla is 100 bucks, you want to buy
a whole bunch of Teslas.
Potentially.
That's not how healthcare, how healthcare
works and that is why the system we have is
a moral, and I was trying to explain this
the other day on a live Twitch stream where
we have a lot of international viewers and
they kept saying, wait David, you're, you're
saying you pay four 21 a month and you still
owe two grand for your appendectomy?
Yes, I pay four 21 a month for the privilege
of limiting what I owe for my appendectomy
to $2,000 rather than the eight or nine or
$10,000 that it will probably end up costing
in total.
This is a big piece of the immorality of the
profit, the for profit healthcare system that
we have.
We will talk about it more upcoming and I
will get you those.
A appendectomy figures once I have them.